[Music]
joining me now is author and commentator
Horus Cooper chairman of project 21
Horus they all make their way to the
Border photo op you know you had AOC
shedding tears mayor Adams now
apparently mayor of Chicago Biden did it
kamla did it they don't seem to care
it's just about taking the photo to make
them look like they're
working well you know that's absolutely
correct that uh they want to do a photo
op but what they're demonstrating is
that black Americans people born who
live in this country have to move to the
back of the political bus progressives
have a new priority a new favored group
people who are not natives of this
country people who have largely broken
the law to enter into this country those
people are now
displacing Americans disproportionately
in our inner cities black Americans the
truth is
the left Mr Biden as I point out in my
book put y'all back in Chains they are
the worst deadbeat dad that black
Americans have ever seen they are
abusing and they're willing to put
another race group ahead of actual
American citizens Horus and and one
other displacement is the displacement
of children right so move aside the
children from the schools for as the
images you just saw on the screen single
adult males kids come last let the
single adult males bring fentanyl across
our border which fentel by the way we
don't know where it came from but killed
a one-year-old here in New York City the
children come last how does the left get
away with
this see a dead be dad does not care
about you a dead be dad does not care
about your child in fact a dead be dead
is ready to have a diance with a new
group almost immediately no matter what
he says the schools in our countries in
our country in our inner cities that so
many black Americans attend are the
worst imaginable how could someone say
they care about you they're looking
about you when they bring in tens of
thousands if not millions of people who
are going to displace your kids you
think your kids can't read at the second
grade level or the fifth grade level
today guess what when the new influx
comes in your kids are just going to be
pushed to the curb we are letting our
children getting poison the dead beat
dad Progressive hates your child would
rather your child be aborted does not
want you to live in a nice home gives
you
substandard public housing
substandard
education and continually
is looking for a new group to come in
and vote in your stad putting you back
at the back of the bus well one thing's
for sure we have a dead beat president
uh no doubt about that Horus thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else